what's up fool podcast going inside your
ears wherever you're at right now
working out driving your 18 foot trailer
or 52 trailer or you're just sitting at
home buyer solved with your head down
man
what's up full podcast it's better to
make you forget about yourself in your
life for a hour and a half we've got
well do you love totally you got a
haircut bro no I just combed it right in
my hair shower in the teenage years we
saw Joker a third time we're off
annihilated bro ed Park in San Antonio
and when he went work Joker would sell
refriger to hide I say look at that's
[ __ ] Rizzo hiding from Cathy what's up
full mansion take everybody who saw our
video from the Portland OR they like
that yeah people couldn't believe you
fit in a [ __ ] locker bro no no my
school didn't have lockers it was ghetto
dude give me a wedgie and toss you in
there in the trash can everyone will
have backpacks grab at me never gets
here Jennifer yeah
Oh me
okay name merinov alaska moon or burn da
moneh better growing six grazing miRNA
right different name with Myrna
everybody's different
yeah she was uh we were told I don't we
were nothing on a school trip to Long
Beach and I was like God by the beach
and then up some girls [ __ ] it started
smoky and the dudes ratted him out we
mail and the girl that girl murder was
like we gave was snappers that was your
children with my ass
we got March of Rizal right here married
already
hey how's it going congratulations I see
the heavens my ears are sensitive
remember what I'm living with my bae
mama her brother had like a is here was
hurt he brought what's wrong well here a
bigger black head in there bro
you like Charlie Charlie the dirty food
on real bro yeah yeah I went up I got
like a hot rag first and it is like the
barbers on rag dog they got two q-tips
and I pretty chapter that she came out
like that huh Wow oh came out dollar
[ __ ] you Bob boy I keep [ __ ]
that WC in pond bro
like wax did I've had explosive ones
before 986 up [ __ ] you don't say
gonna popping I'm ready to blow yeah
well you know what sometimes you can hit
them before they're too early and you
mess your [ __ ] up but this was perfect
did I hit the glass too
no I don't know good skin I had pimples
like crazy the sixth grade like weeks
before the sixth grade graduation I bust
out a big pimp on my face first one was
right here my cheek
it was just came out the next day that
it was like fresh you can get brain
damage from pressure on your nose like
in your t-zone it's possible my mom let
me touch ID let us touch our faces if we
had a pimple no no no no because she had
so many scars I know so many fools they
looking at that poof of Dick Tracy dog
like a steve-o's like just like row
mountainous terrain this teacher
assisted in my that class there by dish
to mr. writer never like think Joanne
and she was in high school brochure one
of the gorditas right other guy who have
a problem and should be leaned over bro
like this huh and up would you see that
brush you'll roll her big boobs on me a
little kids dog right I know the fat
weirdo dude and she [ __ ] like almost
like guy in his lap over other them and
popped it black hit on his nose in the
class dog was it bothering her I guess
my brother's wife is like that she wants
to pop his I'm not into that [ __ ]
the people of Midwest my whole thing is
like dude like if you start annoying
somebody you don't get it our little
suck we gotta go back tomorrow dog
George Carly hat that one joke by here
we got that little bump in pimp or in
your something light in your body and
like you're gonna look forward to
scratching you when you get home
oh yeah that's all you have to live for
will you be scratching hard so it's a
better like I will get like that ingrown
here and I'm like oh man
Lisa get ready you come over you say I
got a project for you so when I would
like well I can't be like that Robbie
dyeing your prickly like my hair goes
into my skin do it and I get the little
buff bro like brothers you know about
scratching I hear stories in Mexico
people I will scratch her but this cuz
they have little buddy says and
tapeworms and they like but their butts
because the potion they're like like
you're not support worms you're talking
about like pin worms that come out of
your anus like like kids get pin worms
cuz they eat a lot of like dirt and
clean the one here is whatever that's
the car its tapeworms I don't know we're
serious talk about its you know what
[Laughter]
walked in the world quickie
just dropped out to be born O's you
think it's like I didn't go ladies all
little like girls that he talks about
like they were shoes this big like did
you perform for kiss somebody got their
throat slit man we walked in it real
quick then they pushed us in there map
basically like it's like 2025 shadow and
then another let us know the next door
we sat inside and as soon as we said it
signed they were pushing a girl in a
gurney like a gurney man and I go for
their paralyzed [ __ ] it is sad in
there would you do know we sell real
quick right and we sell pickpocket money
dawg that's how it is a [ __ ] service
we're outside I'll make you look at
these guys man
these guys gotta jump out of the car to
make ten bucks bro you're walking down a
street and people are just like
harassing you to film that special and
over there man is there for that night
man yeah
let the pinatas come to life right the
movies man you're walking out is that
shut down but no wonder where they shows
down bro it was like man do it but [ __ ]
[ __ ] up yeah everybody like everybody
like the owner of Tommy cheese ball dude
hard times KD KD
they were the cream of money huh
we have a guest here man on we found
that up by a guest from another podcast
right yeah what was that what's not even
Peter Peters oh he oh yes yes okay I
didn't know he had a Spanish yeah it was
amazing my friend Jimmy mess out right
there hooked it up for us
Ernie G and that was there it was gonna
be a half-hour podcast and then it went
to two hours and five minutes so then
from there I'm gonna break that record
man do one hour
two minutes and a half and then I was
hosting the of course the ice house this
last Sunday foretold you go from madlady
I came from East LA where there was
there was warming to that part but like
would you be where you grew up
I grew up in East LA yeah yes yes my
parents gave me away when I was born
because they were having an affair when
they were married to two very famous
people and they were famous themselves
know about too much of it there were not
famous
that was a famous mechanic anymore very
loads of my mom use me so here we go
people ask who was the Mexican host
producer of the television show siempre
Domingo which is the hallmark
contribution to the Latin America were
and eventually to other parts of the
world where Spanish America programs our
broadcast because if you want though if
you were like grew up in America and
you're Latino and you never heard of
over last course you were probably
living under a rock somewhere man
because that fool show will come out all
day and pretty much if you did have a
mom and dad he was your babysitter yeah
you guys show off for hours the water
bro
right without the women without the
without the little stories about a
grandma meeting their son after Friday
show and then also a little Jerry
Springer it was right on the start at
lunch it was a whole block come out and
I saw Van Halen on that show brought
towards the arrow a little kid I'm like
what and I would like and then read
about the other one India Maria yeah
yeah yeah yeah right so watch her movies
and I was younger and then um er the TV
show she had on out what's it called
soul tequila on our channel we should
watch her movies at the drive-in theater
and norwalk the sundown and my dad would
take us there bro and she was a stand-up
comedian funny lady hysterical she just
passed away what about to where do the
others face my dad's on the six so do
your parents my parents liar I was born
you see it yeah can you see her when she
was if you look at money um if you look
at our in their money on photos when she
would matter in character she's a very
pretty lady and row it was like a
[ __ ] player dog let me tell you
something I put his shirt bro the last
row had the [ __ ] show on lockdown bro
like if you were like would the error
that he was on if you you were not you
cannot it was like what you call it our
makers our maker Johnny Carson I'll put
into one yeah so what you say when you
find out through your parents like I
want you don't have any pictures of you
of with them with jewel hero you do my
I'm just shot the pilot for my real were
you born I was born in General Hospital
in East LA are you serious yeah yeah I'm
so from East LA well has to go so that
in highways
I went to San Gabriel High School hey
bruh high school yeah you go to Garfield
oh no no I wasn't East LA she's a hero
messy starter dear
what's her name hope Sam about Hope
Center ball yeah so I used to go to Ford
elementary and then from there I went to
Rose me in high school and sang it with
high school for two high schools dan
that's the room yeah that was awesome
but my parents my my mom was the maid to
my mom and when mom found out she was
pregnant for me and come to know now 50
years later I mean I had 30 years later
she gave a lot of us away and the one
the only oh I I did a DNA what do you
mean she gave she had a lot of
illegitimate I had a bunch of kids I
have eight kids right I've been pregnant
13 times yes 13 my mom they say maybe 20
[Laughter]
that's a shame dad she only kept a
couple her marriage so like Denise Bella
Nova That singer she's actually I had a
DNA test with her because she's doing
she wanted permission I don't know why
for me to do a novela
of my mom just like yalitza she's
actually doing as roma right yeah yeah
yeah she's actually doing the biography
of my mother in Hollywood right and
she's filming right now is he speaking
oh I just talked earlier her and her
sister Luna so they're coming on huh
yeah so I mean I have my sister Corina
from my dad's side my from my mother's
side but God everyone's Televisa Pablo
Velasco like everyone has contacted me
and saying you know what we knew about
you your mom and her deathbed actually
of course you're gonna die if you're
facing you know either you know heaven
or hell
so she actually told the family that's
why were called great strength that's
why that's why you never seen anyone
come out talking anything bad about me
only stupid reporters are idiots you
know thank you thank you and so but yep
when I came out with my daughter or the
DNA test they all shot
not only BC on wants me to be there
after the holidays well they all mean
now that I'm up to the holidays to do a
big interview with me and the velasco's
and be very exclusive about it because
I'm having my own realization of course
who wants the ratings of course allow me
but I give them a lot they did supuesto
a little but you know what I do it right
I step back and I was thinking I had a
daughter of the had cancer I had a son
with autism a daughter mentally
challenged I was on the streets when I
was a little kid my parents my dad right
now is worth 870 million dollars my mom
almost worth with all her net marketing
my husband 937 my mother just won and
I've never never never
why would I know God has blessed me even
on Christmas Day the first lot of red
one was Christmas Day the first one
listen to what I said cracker you
believe it did I bring you a little
bottle you don't even drink that also
I'll enjoy it thank you twice I did the
first one wasn't like the lotto lotto
first one was a dollar quick pick got I
had a little someone tell me in my ear
by a dollar quick pick I did no rabbit
with one dollar quick pick December 25th
Christmas Day will you $1 2009 the first
one oh I want half a million dollars
[Music]
with 10 years ago I know the one that
was a few years ago I actually when I
want I didn't want to receive it I put
in a trust fund for my kids that one was
20 million dollars that you can reach
our people to be the party
breeding tags laughing time do you have
these guys hanging out with you it's
gonna mission 19 the porridge of Roger
Velasco in the hostel your biggest fan
is your brother - no I manage him I say
the last call my mom and dad they
thought that my mom should be they
thought my parents were cousins our
brother and sister because it work
Velasco yeah the way we reproduce we're
the law schools everywhere use no water
or huh breathing make wholesome little
man was all lie down like no down we had
every look at back then yeah that's
great it's always been moppy of course
delivery so everyone knows that it's a
big time so back then imagine 50 years
ago my mother started off as a dancer
she do her Lolo radio she started
playing the guitar trying to act and
people would tell her man you're just an
ugly little Mexican you're damn India
get the hell out of here they would tell
her that and she always tried her best
but they always put her behind the main
beautiful woman behind behind and one
day one of the directors told us you
know what you're just a stupid little
Mexican Indian once you get on a dam
dong can't get the hell out of here my
mom did that she embraced that and she
put two braids on she became indigenous
an India and she got a donkey she named
him feel him on and my mom is almost
almost worth you more feeling more
almost a billion dollars it's like my
dad four years ago my dad the same thing
oh you're four eyes being she ugly want
to be Mexican from Spain yeah and so
they actually embrace what the things
like that that people would throw at
them I go table want osteo Prieto Prieta
whatever and they actually are richer
than most people we know nowadays so you
get along with the family away I love
the Velasco families of
have to say that there it was people
that didn't know anything about me to
compare to that to them they embrace me
they're supporting me with my reality
show TV show I'm in TV series I have my
own movies I've been doing radio for six
years English and Spanish and the
families like whatever you want we're
here
that's beautiful they they all flew in
to where I live out in the high desert
to come and meet me and the kids that's
beautiful I mean they just wanted to hug
me that I've given through so much your
family and we knew about you but your
mom never wanted because can you imagine
now the scandal oh how dumb people got
when I came out with the story imagine
they let the joke in the lottery crazy
and I had an interview with a cheese man
Oh like on Xavier and he goes if your
mother was here look in the camera what
would you tell her right now I go or
honestly what would I tell her without
thinking thank you for not aborting me
because what do you expect when she came
from dirt I even went to Puebla and they
gave me the key to Puebla and I seen
where she was born I mean it was like
you didn't want to spend the day there
or half a day there and I seen how broke
they were and my dad from Celaya Celaya
is all run by mob Brian everyone getting
killed the people that are hung by the
border of people that come from Celaya
the tunnels that were built under our
borders or from celaya they're crazy
narcotic people so imagine back then
they would have killed me so I know deep
in my heart they saved my life giving me
away so I have I have no regrets I have
I have no anger to I love them they're
amazing in your mom's side of the family
what's up with that my mom's side of my
family I actually have a nephew who
lives
seven minutes eight minutes from my
house and he's been up there for 20
years in the high desert and he's like
when I met up with him a few days ago he
calls me up now he goes yeah I knew
about you all this time we were waiting
for you to come up we respected you
we've been following you when your
daughter almost died of cancer when your
son just passed away he was killed all
of these things like they knew like they
knew was going on it felt beautiful
to know that their I mean I knew who
they were I'm watching him from afar
watching them on TV
and they're watching me from afar that
was beautiful yeah when how did you find
out and when did you find out I was four
I was 14 years old my my stepmother had
a beautiful little girl named violet
Violeta and I seen my stepdad which I
thought it was my dad being a little too
nice always hugging her the way he would
carry her and I was like I felt like a
pit as a me I'm a medium by the way I do
it and I got small yeah I felt though
that's how I manifested the lottery a
couple of times and I'm gonna win a
third time laws of attraction don't
forget about us somebody's asking if
you're single thank you
somebody's asking yes I need a sugar
mama some sugah
she said that money's locked up I
actually I work with the company I
actually found out how to cure off the
record I learned the body can cure
itself beauty minerals so my daughter
had Hodgkin's lymphoma four years ago
seven tumor stage three Loma Linda and
so I learned from a doctor a natural
doctor that's actually doctor for
Steadman Oprah the Dallas Cowboys and
the Lakers and I actually made him my
best friend see I was born at night but
not last night and yeah actually yeah
and he actually helped me reverse it on
my daughter and my daughter my son was
the first case of autism that's that no
longer so we can't see cure it's against
FDA Clive been doing really so long but
like my daughter had seven tours we
can't find him anymore
she just gave me my first grandson and
she works at Loma Linda nice my daughter
honor big I seen on my Instagram my
daughter is the spitting image of my mom
when I was pregnant with her the doctors
would say they would give you something
called the amniocentesis because I was
over 37 I mean 27 and and they told me
you should have an abortion
they call it DNC they won't say abortion
and in a few months you get pregnant
again your cue to have another kid so I
didn't listen I kept my daughter and she
is my mom reborn again
she's a spitting image and she was born
with mental retardation and she does
circles around me right now so that's my
come
so most of people that I work with are
around our company with minerals and I'm
known for curing it's not about my mom
and dad the only reason I came out it's
because I found out when I was little
that this wasn't my real parents and
when I went and took them I told my
counselor about my father
my stepfather they put us in a foster
home
so from East LA I went up to Palmdale
and then and court my stepmom pulled me
by the arm role ugly aggressive me she
goes you know what Corona we're not even
your real parents your parents are big
icons remember ways to make you watch
sampan Domingo I like yeah that's your
dad and that's your mom and so from then
on 14 and on till now I've been on my
own and God has been good to me I just
like got mad and left like I just I I
when the foster knew it I was not my fan
[Laughter]
bro all right bro Nicolas Cage
which one you were the weatherman and
then he woke up in a regular family oh
yeah this is my life I told her I don't
belong here to the SUV to having kids
that was awesome moving I know going out
of here yeah it is going to it is going
to I think our left channel is going out
in our yeah I hear more on the right I
don't know if anybody else hears it or
if it's just is it part of the audio
broadcast
I've heard of sugar mamas by Terry sugar
Diaz
yeah sugar Thea she grew up in a foster
home for how many years I was in a
foster home probably a few weeks after
that I ran away I ran away boy ran away
wouldn't know I ran away like a month
after I was there I just I just sorta
Dean I took up at we were living it from
there I went down to East LA back to LA
to Rosemead and I just brought myself up
I raised myself you're living in the
street to it I'm a I'm kind of cute so
I've had I used to be a promoter
I used to promote red onion in West
Covina Fantasia nightclub at the
Bonaventure and of course led the
one-time rule yeah I run away from home
bro and although they were not called
jr. next to Fantasia
yeah and they were took the back used to
be close and I snuck in there bro and I
fell asleep bro that's awesome
that is awesome I said I would do but I
was so blessed that I had so many DJ I
should be a DJ then at all you guys do
you what I was later Teddy Boys I would
I was Lady Vogue yeah I used to work
with Caesars scene de niro Caesar De
Niro hi Cesar I love you I'm just
kidding you pare Canada and the Teddy
Boys a long time ago and I was the only
girl promoter I would get a cut from the
door and a cut from the bar
I was always I'm a hustler you have to
be right when you're living on the
streets and so that's why I not because
of the lottery but I'm a self-made
millionaire so what did you want with
these clothes offend you de fantasía
back in the day and red onion okay I was
okay I turned a Pink Panther sugar
daddies into caddies that's to go to
carries that was my daddy's broke caddy
throw it to be a it was a San Gabriel
golf course
mana balanced by the is where the Hat
and that place was eight o'clock to a
midnight are never free admission but
our daughter drinks I mean come on I'm
answer park al-mansur park answer pie
that yeah
yes yeah three rooms yes yeah we should
do that brandy so as to do Brandy's I
used to do let me see of course club
massage it was across the street from
the quite Canyon baby those are you
doing candy baby does Robert Magnum yeah
I was the only girl per I was the only
girl that would do it that were DJ and
get okay thank you Jill do caddies back
in the day like in 1994 yes I did I used
to were also have a magnet without a
rehab right horoscopes for what's up
magazine oh [ __ ] I swear horoscope
species have you guys seen the podcast I
actually did a reading on pinche Peter
and I'm our theme oh yeah we had a
medium michael month ago right yeah did
she give you a reading
was it go yeah he gave ended up being me
you're surprised because I could read
you Jude I read him Joe okay so I could
tell that you had okay I could tell that
you have a really hard time sleeping
you'll have reoccurring nightmares okay
I guess yeah older lady I don't know
it's a mom or grandma dad you actually
have a connection with and you always
think about a lot you don't admit it to
people because you have a very private
private life that you only share with
yourself which is don't to share it
share it know your tea but the bright
side you have a really good heart and
those of us that had a really bad
childhood we want to do what we give
what we don't have you want to give love
you want to make people laugh and that's
up gimmefive I admire you for that buddy
but you're amazing and I didn't want
[Applause]
come on okay you had a brother named
John I see you have a [ __ ] good
growing bro and your past you were a
trained animal
the guy the guy in the middle dude go to
Hong Kong you would to Chikako globey
I actually went okay I was gonna
actually could you do a reading for me
yes I could do a reading you actually
have two little boys around you
[Applause]
there was no flyer for this event
[Laughter]
you see the ghosts upon the dead I could
actually see you're a very sensitive guy
and you're very close to your family
yeah you had a really good thing with
your mother didn't you yeah but she's
still alive yeah I could see that so
beautiful we have a really good heart
are they appreciate yeah I had I went on
a cruise few years ago okay and so I was
a little tipsy and so when I'm like that
I'm just open so I just start reading
everybody very cute so I was coming out
of the cruise and I saw this lady and I
said and a little baby started pulling
my leg and I looked around and it felt
like it was real but it was a spirit and
I went I looked at this lady and I said
I'm sorry for the loss of your son and
then she was there with her fiance why
they've never had sex before
and so she's looking at me she wants to
just shoot my head army and I said I was
tipsy I was like yeah it's all deny you
give him a name your baby died you know
and I could tell you how to an abortion
and she was looking at me and she turned
right as her shirt and she was so pissed
off and my friend grabbed me I was like
dang so they were getting off I went to
the restroom she followed me and she
goes I'm sorry it's just I never I've
never been with him that's my fiance I
was like oh I'm so sorry so now I'm very
reserved what I bring up you know where
we're live right now
I got herpes but I'll give you know give
you guys one-on-one with you guys ever
want one yeah I know you need one really
bad I do going did they try to do
anything up with the cleanse about a
cleanse
yes no they didn't tell me plans were
clan I think your connection saw me you
mean like an internal cleanse or
cleansing like no that's sort of I know
he can I know he stays up a lot worrying
a possibly stresses out he does but I
know it's awfully base felt stress at
David I think you know there's one thing
I teach my kids believe nothing you hear
not for you see credit do today I'm
actually picking up I'm picking up on
your aura on your spirit my my
girlfriend to him because she believes
in all that stuff and she went to she
goes to the schaeffler or personal what
they call the tarot reader is killing of
a she needs to see her tarot card reader
and she needs to see a gynecologist once
a year that's
[Laughter]
she's only that she asked her about me
and she told me that while my
ex-girlfriends put a hex a hex on me as
a self-made millionaire you know what
I'm talking about
not only that for just eight kids but I
produced a marine with honors an
attorney for a Nintendo a biochemist
becoming oncologist so I'm kind of I
have a good track record for Nintendo
she produced I produce on my own money
because I never charge I want you guys
to do I want you guys to go and get some
scissors I want you to open the scissors
all the way up and put tape around it I
want you to pick up your mattress pick
up your mattress and put it under your
mattress that's to repel any spells you
have on you go get some salts when you
take a shower put it and clean yourself
with salts in the Bible it says go and
be the salt of the earth your have to
but it just says it's joy yes is showing
I'm telling you how powerful salt is
okay when people don't listen they turn
around and be sarcastic they become a
pillar so my hope be careful to put some
loans right yes yes exactly it's very
powerful so when you guys go home when
you guys I'm gonna give you guys a spot
to go home right now open a good one
okay you're gonna go home when you're
gonna take off your shoes I want you to
face them out of your mattress because
any [ __ ] this isn't a cow
[Laughter]
you were drunk every game one she was
facing out she was facing now Martin's
taking notes until you know that you
know and if you want to go one step
further you get the salt and you walk
around your house or the outside of
their house yes you think good thoughts
and this is what I can listen if I want
money or advice I'm not gonna ask the
bum on the street I'm gonna go to Bill
Gates yeah okay so if you guys want to
know from someone that's made it it's
making it will always make it I've done
it cuz I've had so many there's a lot of
jealous people around me obviously
that's why everyone in Hollywood yeah I
don't read it I don't believe in all
that I just I'm just blessed and highly
favored all right but if you guys
because we're in the industry people see
us on YouTube I'm unspecial as it all
around the world people are very jealous
so you're always gonna protect yourself
because he will give you like they say
that you boy bad juju bad juju I gotta
open the scissors put tape around it
like it on my mattress my shoes facing
out every night wash myself with salt a
curse on your course on my career your
career yeah what's definitely like
complaining about how you're broke all
the time she was just asking oh ya know
about me you know cuz she was just
telling in there Julie I see your
boyfriend he's not you're trying to
what's it called something about the
entertainment business and they're like
somebody put a like a curse on me yeah
did they put it on Johnny rule 20 or 31
years lopes put your hair Yeah right
look weird do you have nightmares
no they mirrors D Marissa no no no you
have any lucid dreams before okay you
did yeah okay so this talked about you
think we were paralyzed so when I saw
that
okay so when I tell you what we have msg
senses meter reading it's kind of a
shocker so you'll remember after all
dang I remember that after yeah so right
now you remembering when you had not to
like paralysis how long ago I probably
like a month ago because I was very yeah
because I there's a while I was getting
those in like quite frankly frequently
okay yeah what does that mean it's the
proud okay what was your dream about I
don't remember it was just asleep rouses
right yeah just like I couldn't move
okay so you are awake I was awake but I
was okay you are trying okay so you were
awake and you couldn't move your body
yeah okay so when we go to sleep just
like the Sun the Sun never sleeps it
goes around the earth right
I wrote it cuz its energy all of us are
energy you were saying that you believe
in law of attraction yeah I picked up
from your earlier right yeah okay so
when you go to sleep you don't need all
your son in other words your energy
inside of you so you come out and you
you're traveling that's why you could be
somewhere Phillipe and say oh my damn
thing when I've been here but I never
been here before
well you actually have when you're
asleep your your body your car you go
you're in parked in your garage but
you're actually out there doing astral
traveling I know I teach like Beyonce
and Madonna which I'm allowed to say no
they gave me rights to say it I teach
them how to do that I've been doing it
for years I even baptized Lourdes
madonna's daughter
maybe she watching us right now but I've
taught them because I've learned so much
you know and it's not that it's out of
necessity
being on the streets of 14 rightly said
you would think my god and to me it was
like I'm gonna be a good mom on a be a
good this to that I'm gonna have amazing
children and I just focus on my kids and
I brought them all up but you you have
someone is trying to get you right now I
don't know I have to see your your hands
yeah if it does good what I could see
that you put your nose that you're very
you're very sensitive so you're an easy
target and you are you're an easy target
good carjack ten times stop Jack you
know you could be nice yeah yeah but
it's someone very close to you that's
screwing you oh yeah someone that
doesn't want to see you succeed
sometimes the ones closest to us are the
ones that are first excuse me [ __ ] us
oh you know yeah so if you really get it
get a cup get a glass cup with water and
put a carnation in there put it under
your bed and ask your spirit guides ask
your guardian angel where you want to
call it what if you can't get a
carnation yeah you could get a carnation
the hell I'm at Vaughn's date or
brother's get a little wife with a
clever incarnation you know and ask and
and get and they'll give you the name of
your guardian angels will give you the
name of the person cuz you deep down
your we know who it is but your ego is
blocking it well you know what it's
someone really close to you who's the
dog that's green yo oh that's very
personalized it's only between you and
you I don't know yeah you do know you do
know what is you know I could see it in
his sock as soon as I seen oh so it is
because he's easily I couldn't be no no
it is who told you that though that your
company is cursed
it was Stephanie's somebody put off she
the one up go their work everyone
she asks about you girlfriend and then
she asked about me and that somebody
told her that somebody put a curse on me
like if somebody I ate it before and
then I need to do a cleanse
honey oh honey oh sorry how new is a new
new and how old is the old old so all
these like how long was the old like uh
three years barely
okay three years ago with her I was with
her for like three years three years
three years ago and I'll see you in
what's in three years so 336 got it yeah
and then this Stephanie over two years
yeah yeah it's a hex from the x-axis mom
yeah she's the one from like she's from
Mexico right our south side or right
she's got some some of them what's our
full December 27th to 31st I'm gonna be
a stand-up live get those tickets now
Ontario California it sold out we added
a second show on January 5th Sunday 9
o'clock
Pleasanton California Tommy T is January
9 through 12 Dallas Addison improv
January 17 through 19 the one at my head
called January 22nd Tiwa bodega Santa
Cruz California generally favored at the
catalyst sent to Ana California Jenna 28
that's gonna be the Spanish special
people yeah right away I see fine sold
out there's no that amazing amazing day
hey legit that's so mater this this
Sunday
you're in big turbo California at the
Holiday Inn no that's the 22nd I'm
inviting you guys Philippe atleast I'm
inviting you guys to one of my favorite
restaurants I'm actually on the menu and
it's probably like I don't know a
hundred three hundred feet away from the
holiday and because you're up there
early
I'm not going you're not gonna go no I
don't what's it called restaurant door
it's called like a sit down they're
vegan foods are big enough anything for
you I'm like this with the owners oh
yeah
hi Freddie love you yes yes they
actually make me lobster they don't sell
Lobster their attraction man yes so it's
gonna be awesome though is that first
time that you're going to a Victorville
yes first time I had ever been there
never done a gig out there I don't know
that the food that has that where
Sebastian had a show I he put us up at
the the Castle Rock Inn or some kind of
Castle Castle Rock is in Vegas no I used
to perform at the Tilted Kilt
I remember out there that's a victory
yeah there's one Victorville out of
those huh everywhere in my friend zone I
mean yeah he's my partner oh she
actually helped me open up a couple bars
that's cool what's his name you know
what are you he acts like he's a poorest
guy on the planet and he taught me to
drive instead of my cars little cars
I learned it for him but he's released
on his Fareed probably the richest man I
know really yeah he's awesome though
he's an awesome promoter
hey man his brother he's all family it's
his mom and his brothers you know right
they live right behind where I live oh
oh house behind me used to go port at
the hop and up with their International
House of Pancakes that was back then huh
now hoppy and make wouldn't happen up
with this up went the ending with two
spots house the only place we are me
good look upon our mom and her daughter
like here crazy
so what after caddies or how did you
start like getting into promoting that's
so young you know young I used to know
la classe Quinta Narrows
how did you like meet them like wake up
and tired of being a promoter how do i
wake up i hooked up when I was at sang
about high school I met a guy named
Selby so you popular in high school
Selby but I didn't like school of course
did you buy whatever do my work all the
time but I met Selby was which was the
outsiders Fantasia are we heard that
promoter I heard a Fantasia
okay that was here to Livan downtown in
yeah but there was a problem a group
called The Outsiders that actually Oscar
the holiest cousin Rudy was part of
that's how I met him and Oscar that's
how we all hung out and he actually
taught me how to DJ how to promote I was
with him I had my first kid at 17 he was
one of my best friend's right now we
actually just did two years sha they had
a concert at the casino Bicycle Club a
couple of weeks ago I hadn't got with
him but I get along with all my exes you
know their wives or girlfriends or
Sanches bunch of I'm just punching and
I'm like that you know why because after
you bury a child Lisa you say you know
what when I'm not here any longer what
how do I want my kids to be treated by
their exes by their friends by people so
I got a plant a generational blessing
instead of a curse I mean I've been
around a lot so I know I've learned a
lot I'm not perfect I'm still learning
but I know that when you do good deeds
you plant good seeds good things happen
to you you know and this is why we say
to protect yourself because we're in the
eye of the camera so a lot of people
want to be after us of course they're
gonna be jealous of you look at her
gorgeous girl she's the beautiful and I
wouldn't be if it wasn't for her I love
her
I'm taking her home what kind of bar
we have bottle girlfriends do it this is
our last show of the year by the way
[Applause]
stand up in Spanish - what do you have
going on right now
so Roger Velasco and myself the first
amazing Power Ranger with the biggest
heart by the way the big heart over here
tambien
he actually we actually are in Sangre
negra TV series with Estrada black blood
Erik Estrada Estrada man I'll be
starstruck of Ezio yeah why don't you
call me we go back on said you were to
reconnect my heart broke Lopez yeah but
he loves Mexican Spanish when he was
doing that novela yeah but he probably
like chopped you know to get back to his
like you know just chops this piece take
a picture you guys maybe a No thank you
40 - hey that's not sure dear a was
drinking from that [ __ ] that [ __ ] me
a favor Russell I don't like to buy
cheap stuff you guys come on
that's a bottle that DeRay wanted and
they want to go buy it oh they're gonna
pay for this so you're V okay so I have
that I I just shot my pilot for my
reality show
forget the Kardashians it's so mexicanos
those Belasco's I'm actually with
everyone from my mom's side and my dad's
side
let's get 1942 over there you guys are
going to get oh I just want to know that
I'm trying to start a podcast network
and I need some investors bullshitty but
then you brought that bottle of a
goddamn 1942 Julio yeah but you don't
drink I don't know so I'm gonna get so
I'm gonna get you are having my own
thing Keylong mly I'm gonna bring a
server and my kids and my wife oh yeah
you guys come over here come on oh he's
gonna come on come on Jamie Stephanie
Roger
look Philly but you have you have such
amazing people as your audience you have
celebrity you see my hair man five
people right here Haiti of the year
trim got impeach so Nizar then do the
toast we will be back after January 8th
I think it's very odd people
[Applause]
that's not that harsh mr. bloop whatever
your name is I gotta block you dude
go [ __ ] your mommy trying to tell us how
to market the show and they're not
enough people watch it's like dude this
is a first time here I did it I did an
interview and it started off with I
think 50 or 100 people and it's almost a
million right now oh [ __ ]
so it's like you know come over here and
I play was on YouTube as on YouTube
wouldn't you start performing and
started messing with radio and all that
so I've been doing it for six years when
I was able to make tumors disappear in
autism and mentally then I started to
disappear I don't have any stretch marks
but I read them though the back of the
knee caps on the haul roads there out
there out there I have three kids that
were daughters she did this sweet in
she's happy we're talking every morning
on Instagram I love that I was Sonia my
shoe offered to tweet on my list did you
text it not yet well then you better
yes my wife make the Milan I make
excellent you can tamales the Czech
fruit and then the red sauce and then i
make chili and cheese with vegan cheese
and then wait wait you say that i push
in there girl and I put episode a in my
masa so where are you from ELISA I call
Dayton Ohio
but you said come in does it does Wow
I'm not latina but but I did know
Spanish before I met him yes I studied
it tastes like Stephanie have really
good taste with my love it yeah it's
sorry oh sure so I have la Strava
Sudha's de la familia Velasco Mira
Belasco and right now we have Netflix
and espanol and HP own espanol that
there they want to look at it so I don't
know if I'm gonna probably just out of
my pocket produce my own show I don't
know yet but I do have a clothing line
coming up with Roger Velasquez mom that
target is gonna take over I want
something that's affordable beautiful
and affordable I don't want to go to
Macy's Nordstrom because it's just come
out we're normal people someone if you
told me you're from a dynasty two
dynasties a legacy I'm the kid I'm just
from East LA yeah you know we had
cockroaches we grew up we had wrought
bass you know are you really yard sales
I do you associate with your adoptive
parents yes I actually call them your
parents or what my father my
stepfather's doing 20 years as a
convicted child molester this is what I
say people love atopic is that my
parents okay
my parents gave me away to my mother and
then she decided you know and then she
got what she was married but it was hard
your mom
hide you from premise for to my mom well
dresses yeah probably my mom has always
there's a picture they send me that
she's always covered up yeah so she
always has wraps around her because she
wasn't day like that how she she was
very family yeah so when she gave me
away when she gave me away
she always still go to beat those
gordita you know and so they can't meet
him for two years I didn't have a name
so a reporter brought up my birth
certificate and for two years Lisa it
was only Velasco and then it was Amanda
but they hit me as a little boy so he's
actually pictured and Roger has seen
these picture of my father role Velasco
pushing me as a little boy he will go
they will meet at a park my step parents
and my parents was Harlem apart you know
what is bought in banks what is the one
back there on the back park
can you imagine Roly Belasco Halle Berry
that party just by pictures
yeah you think you would've got
recognized oh man do it yeah yeah let's
go out of that suit he could blend in
good glasses and a glory thought but he
actually looked just like himself and
I'll show you guys after the podcast
I'll show you guys I just don't post
them up I'm parking the posted stuff
when I have the reality show for ratings
of course you know keep it all under
wraps
yeah yeah yeah but I know that they
already came out with the pictures the
DNA with my sister and that's my mom's
real daughter Denise Bella I'm gonna be
her but I know other singers they were
pretty big you guys heard it but I know
that oh yeah it's in the erotic Spanish
truck man yeah that's my sister
what wait really so Denise is another
daughter my mother gave away huge fan of
elenova that's my [ __ ] I'm in my sleep I
just took a DNA test and she's actually
doing she got she wanted permission to
do my mom's novella so yeah Lisa
Mauricio is doing the biography of my
mother and then my sister's doing the
novella of my mother yeah yeah they show
all the crap put together with all my
kids how many kids do they have together
right in the middle just you or I'll
actually meet up with my attorney
tomorrow 11 o'clock I have five people
either help you win we have good
attorneys right so this was me there
antiparasitics but it was real
medication probably a little mold a and
here and here's me okay that's me when I
was a little boy and there's my dad
pushing the stroller let me see let me
see let me see you dog that's that
Linkin Park
I think apart yeah like Heights
you can't buy the shoes or little girl
shoes and I'm just like a boy SATA I'm
on the one the right hand side and who's
the lady right here that was my kid
other day I would take care of me was
always Ritchie yeah she looks like the
lady kills Elena or the lady that Arnold
Schwarzenegger had the baby I never they
send me pictures but there's not a
picture of my real parents with my step
parents it was always someone in between
a buffer that's right there that's me
right there do you think they wanted to
his back because it really said that
we're so poor and they were having an
affair
did you I'm an affair yeah how can you
have an affair and then you produce one
and then they keep you away because my
mom's known for giving so many kids away
and your mom and your ma your mama
if I could wish she married when she was
and did her husband know about the
pregnancy so he never found out about
the pregnancy because she's all those
kids she was trust you she travels so
much EMV tomorrow
but the thing is what I did is Latino I
wanted to show my parents on both sides
of the spectrum that how to be a good
parent I named all of my kids Velasco on
the birth certificate is only my name as
a mother to put the father and that's
strong child support I don't and I never
do that and then someone told me well
I'm gonna pull everything out go ahead
you need somebody to put on a swing when
by the time you had the shot your
children and those guys were ok with you
because I've always had celebrities come
to my house I actually have they had a
silent disclosure where they will never
talk what's going on and they're they're
okay and so they they own you of course
they own you that's why they're all so
happy that I came out they all need the
truth it's hard to keep it when you have
some people community yeah celebrities
come in our house like it's the pinche
Nopalea for me stelae why am i our
people come in here our house are famous
and so I had to tell them this flyer
girl here yes that's fine so you know
what to replace caddies na me you who do
you know I would you go that's before my
time I think what did you 27:28 I'm a 32
yeah you are you 17 that was like the
clubs
I'm yes the N ba that's not all sir yeah
I seen on Whittier Boulevard
I'm um that yeah I remember yeah yeah
those that I go to tea places no see
oh they're big trucks EXO let's go like
this
nobody talks [ __ ] more about new
immigrants the mexican-american GP was a
poverty middle school which is short for
tune panel that's like a real bad
[ __ ] special only people call you
wetbacks where other other wetbacks yeah
though the one that brothers got all
dressed up bro and polish do what I do I
actually wear watches I had Rogers dad
bring me some from Colima made from real
young tires on the bottom young pass and
I hosted with Olga briefs keen and real
agony and she said she's gorgeous
January Vera's family mom down gave me a
picture in her backpack they send me a
picture of my mom with her on stage and
then a couple of weeks ago I was with
her on stage I was able to give her a
recognition and the Rivera face you have
family members do last media Maria
studio all the kids that they actually
accept it there's no other kids that we
know up and I have my mother she never
had no kids from someone else to give my
she gave all away knowledge she kept two
or something a boy and a girl
there from her marriage how does she
know that those are from her marriage
and then these other I mean she out
there just having sex with everybody
what's the deal
to get into a mentor and I wanted to
learn horny lady on Molly you were to
get somebody pregnant every time you had
sex you would have one thousand a
million right now me 12 a virgin I'm
pretty late in life so for I've always
being protected on the pill dip Rivera
and I co had baby how do you have my
parents like that had nothing might stop
buying your pills from you know what are
you something crazy
I love the diaphragm and I want to I'm
gonna get married again I'm looking for
a victim I mean no husband tobe you got
some brain they could really focus on
his comedy who's Christine all of us
know somebody Birds me
it do issue it gives you a head change
[Music]
you don't have any uncles and aunts from
either side to come out yeah Pablo okay
I've had Carrie Velasco my sister she's
from my father she's into sexual yoga
she's Arbor command pictures please yeah
yeah we proved she actually has I mean
she's a self-made almost billionaire you
know and she's actually no I can't say
anything about legal stuff should be a
Joe Rogan podcast you know problem
Alaska that's one of the honchos for
Televisa one of the most handsome men I
know my sober you know - yeah let me
Sonya know he's gorgeous gorgeous leg I
know I think I'm like 42 43 is young
well to me he's young - I mean I'm 42
million get out of your back cracking
without you want it's my knee and
everyone every one of my mom's side like
Deniz want something to do with the
money neither do i and then the one I
mean it always lends legitimacy to a
story when somebody doesn't want any
money from it you don't need you know
what and this is what I'm what am i
teaching my kids I teach my kids how to
make it on your own I don't get welfare
I don't get SSI when I need it enough
nothing ever I've always worked and I'm
very proud of you I've always been a
hustler I'm a mover and a shaker from
East LA I am I mean uh sorry you'll have
to you know to get out of that and
having so many babies I'm like normally
be well my babies right eight baby seven
or seven are still living babies I think
winter snake is falling for you here so
fascinating and full of energy high
winter snake wait what I've been the
wizards of snake hello
passive wipe discreet winter snake I
love you peace ok enough engaging with
the winter hey baby he's gonna record I
know partisan it to us I have my 9 year
old Mia Savannah color banana that's
your daughter here my daughter she's
actually gonna be on the next spider-man
movie yeah she's in [ __ ] she's on my
job sure his dad actually helped me a
lot in my radio so cool yeah I'm a huge
fan yes and you guys could follow me
what so should me you're asking me quiet
you just read our mind so why not take a
break with my GPS I love Lisa can I have
her I love your wife I don't even know
you you have kitty alarm still taking
her so on Facebook is Judi Ju dy Belasco
is judy judy Velasco yeah why why Judy
you you're asking yourself
porque every a degree from no longer
bringing a bottle 1942 yeah I hate to
use hard tequila's hard for me but this
is not harsh at all really snotty no you
cannot I know this was Roger velasco's
ideas belong Roger Roger Velasco I got
me hookers yes really good tea doesn't
screw off you gotta
Roger once more good that's good I have
a question for you Roger I think it was
tequila 1492 yeah oh yeah we got this
you gotta hook up the Power Rangers hey
okay Green Ranger range so it could be
all about me talking about myself which
we like to add comedians we like to
edify ourselves blah blah uh-huh but
what about you you know me for how long
tell me about me 45 minutes I'm here I
[Music]
hate a lot of people on the Internet
no she's incredibly weird rugger you
robot nobody helped you rehab just gonna
put me in the wheel right yeah did you
do some before the first Mexican Power
Ranger here the Blue Ranger because he
loved Sudan yo
not Carter he he should have been in a
[ __ ] song cooperate what the [ __ ] two
years ago I was a marshal I got blessed
to be that me to go the last marshal you
were yeah I didn't suffer during parade
we need a puta yeah yeah so so that's it
I came out of South Gate I met Myrna
recently she's incredible she said she's
an amazing woman she's got an incredible
heart still a lot of money still you
need that incredible investors Leah
that's secondary she knows that she
knows that I appreciate her heart word
side and she helps a lot of people
honestly she really does I see her do
some amazing things on show some media
I'm in person and I'm just attracted to
that I like really good people have good
intentions which is why I'm here with
tensions it's just important mama alone
son alone in a Velasco dog I'm a huge
fan Stallone I would use my alleppey man
I love premising everybody's people I
need to know
[Laughter]
[Music]
but yeah she's amazing it's a blessing
of beer she's an incredible girl so
she's our manager
she's my man what she did for you to
cleanse knows you cut your pay I wanted
to ask you so why did you ask me if I
had been told to cleanse myself why did
us I forgot I just three demonic demons
could I see three demonic spirits around
you really - ladies ladies in a man is
one of them my mother I see you ladies
are from her family and one is a third
party could have been a grandfather are
they all dead Mel did God know they live
in her house - our three Jomon
experienced two women and a man and I
see that Twitter more dead there's only
one lady in life
hmm and that lady is more demonic than
all 20s my mother
okay ladies for reals bro oh I see yeah
three demonic spirits what are they
doing just like hanging out over my head
or what
Italian fiber that thing is that there
are attached useful
so from pretend you're in heaven are you
so I love this I love that I love that
so we're gonna renew your vows I'm gonna
be in like I need to be there okay right
over those first bells again you're
scaring Winterhaven over here what just
went down yeah right now I'm I'm working
on her reality show just by default it
all happened so I'm getting egged on
which is really exciting about that and
we're gonna be hosting the TV show about
her you know he's doing behind the
scenes and all the people that she's
helping and blessing you don't know hear
a lot of this stuff seriously I just
like you guys and at first it's like
okay I hear it I hear it but the more I
come around and I hang out with Myrna I
meet this people and the confirmations
and people are telling me she helped my
family with this you helped me family
with that so um you know there's a
situation right now with my family and I
brought her in and she's gonna bless my
sister my sister was going through some
challenges right now and I'd heard what
she did with her daughter and you're her
son and a lot of people is up for that
matter so I'm really excited that she
gets to help me with my sister because
she's there to my heart faith can I say
about your sister his sister has MS and
the mom was a big-time fashion designer
which now she quit everything she's
doing now she's gonna go with me what a
blessing that is that she's actually
helping me because she knows what I've
been through my struggles and it's not
about the money Lisa because when I
buried my son 15 months ago he didn't
take [ __ ] with him believe it he just
took what kind of person what kind of
son a friend he passed away his wife
killed them or
this is if you guys you guys haven't
done your honey
oh no we like to run blind to our
interviewer my son was a marine and he
was married his beautiful white girl my
beautiful baby girl Sydney my baby one
of my best friends I love her and so he
met he was a sergeant in the Marines
Camp Pendleton this young little girl I
miss I'm sorry trailer trash okay I was
trailer trash a little bit they had war
together two times got pregnant and she
says I know you love babies like your
mom does either I'm gonna have an
abortion or or divorce your wife and be
with me after like six weeks my son big
heart came to medical mijo well I don't
want her that's my grandchild my son
divorced I paid for the divorce
Cacciatore divorced them I took him to
Vegas and married them where's my son I
did we get married just support the
child is what she wanted because it was
up to me how it was all planned out shut
up had no tag hello
okay so they divorced Chaco new Vegas
they got married that the baby a few
months later she my son comes to me says
mom I'm going to Japan I go what the
hell you're going to Japan sorry man we
[Laughter]
can laugh about it we have I love that
about you so then they divorced I didn't
married them they had the baby he comes
to me goes mama but you're an ordained
minister too no I paid for it oh she
actually did the ceremony
okay I'm at GOP I am the godmother of
the Raiders Coliseum member caper he's
responsible for bringing the Raiders
from Oakland to Las Vegas
I am the godmother Hey
generator and I'm opening up a chat boy
he's like what the hell okay I'll open
up a chapel
another gorilla guy as a hustler from
East LA I've learned to to make money
wherever from making money from this cup
right now making money per year I'm
charging when I was with charging us on
patreon right I'm sorry so he goes to
Japan it was to give him an a two months
later so he was a Marine keep in mind he
was a Marine
I always have pools in my house or
puddles or whatever want to call it
puddles I might have my own beach oh
yeah right
so two months later she calls me at 4:15
in the morning I met Danny Trejo hey you
want a donut easy bands and she called
me at 4:15 in the morning and I said
late alma wordy so she calls me like
really hard really means she calls me
she goes she didn't say I'm sorry we
tried to sugarcoat it before he tells
your kid is dead she goes I just came
back from identifying your dead son's
body I say what I just got like what and
I hear my granddaughter back on
screaming her head off I'm thinking this
me and this [ __ ] never calls me and
plus at 4:50 in the morning I said you
know what I know I'd like to cuss I go
what the [ __ ]
michaela this is not funny what he
what's going on and she goes oh he's
[ __ ] dead and right there and then I
got like something like this is
something's wrong something is wrong I
go you know what I'm gonna call you back
later on I hung up I lost control of my
feet I found the ground and I said oh my
god I'm gonna go to sleep because it
seemed true of course it was true she
was there too a week later from Japan to
Victorville we had to bury him every but
you want to get in and renting
she went against he saw everything you
wanted she even put on the little paper
they give you where he was born
everything she put he was born in
Victorville my leg like she know [ __ ]
about her husband how long had they been
here for months
no two years Oh 24 months she was a 22
year old she
she came she made him when they had the
baby I didn't know this she made him
quit being a Marine but she continued
paying the insurance so she got $400,000
when his body washed ashore the guy that
was with him she set it up with him to
go snorkeling she backed off last minute
but took his is when you ring and his
wallet why because when she walked into
my house she had that on and I'm
thinking wait I mean that's top rate of
wallet about my son cos would be great
offense alone you know I bleed sore and
I said wow that's crazy but because
she's a white girl the guy was a
sergeant in the Marines my son was a
little Mexican with the big cactus here
and he was no longer marine they said
get the hell out of here
three weeks later she'd be got half a
million dollars well how did he die she
set it up to go snorkeling last minute
she took his ring his wallet took off
and a sergeant the Marines took him to
swim even though they were hot it's in
the paper in the news there were high
tide warnings do not go in the water
do not go this marine the sergeant took
him in my son washed ashore they found
him facedown and that guy had one
scratch on him so this day hasn't come
and say I'm sorry for your loss so I
started thinking thinking two weeks
after my son passed away he came he in
another from their spirit world he came
and he pulled my blankets philippe and
send me up my son and I got up and I
looked and of course I was you know
terrified you know and I seen my son and
he looked so well rested and I seen like
this big pillow for light it's so a that
called me and I sat up in the bed and I
said Jonathan God you look so beautiful
honey I go and he started disappearing I
go honey you you have no body just think
about what you're saying just think
don't talk and he started coming into
focus which is kind of where to say that
but this is what really happened and I
said mijo I have two questions before
you leave two questions he goes yeah
what mom I could give you attitude
I knew that I was always honest he's
always I love you sweet I I baby boy
seriously Southgate hello oh yes Cypress
Hill his brother come on hello Oh piano
piano piano race Linda so we came to
Mike what son I have two questions he
goes yeah mom I go first of all I've
been a good girl for nothing and I
equals what I'll go is there a god he
goes mom yes and he adores you I go
second question were you murdered were
you murdered because you know I was he
disappeared and I started thinking a
picking away because my thing is that
after having all these special needs
kids and cancer kids I said you know
what I'm gonna hide Lisa I'm gonna hide
go to the high desert and just be normal
because saying look what it got me
I don't even know my parents they threw
me away like trash so I'm gonna be
different than my parents I'm gonna
raise my kids and just adore them and
not put their their needs special needs
out in the public because you know
people are so cruel look at come on we
had a block right now this looks like
he's all sad like you're making where
the Power Rangers
I do
what's up fool that shows coming up
anywhere in 14th
oh yeah we have a Spanish show with
Martine Moreno and Martin Raziel and
myself in Riverside of you little cheese
tease you know this little bit oh and
this Sunday when is that
January 14th we are yeah yeah but that's
January 14th you're a person those
podcasters are today Victorville this
Sunday but it's sold out awesome key to
the place I like to get there like as
soon as I write go up like we get there
in the show starts all right now waiting
all right know hanging out with nobody I
like to do this show and that's where's
my ankle is that because your wife is
right here we don't want nothing to
block us from injuries to the show to
get here everyone is waiting for you
were close shirts at me my company I'm
not about that [ __ ] shirt on a
throwing yes so the reason I'm here we
gotta give a big shout out here - Jimmy
massacre what is Jimmy is a governor fat
boy
you know I've known read more in also
the guys the best town be careful
dropping names over several people in it
and I have meet your friends with Felipe
we I think we coincided a couple times
was it wrong and Felipe turn me on to
some wonderful people I could drop their
name right yeah our buddies from oh now
let's get up for a got to see Rick
Garcia from El Sereno he's got the other
those particles down there Felipe
several times then he told us that tacos
were freaking good about Kalia - yeah
yeah that's right
two years ago boy I've never had it but
it's good yeah they have the Bombers a
little luck the cups yeah that's what my
girl will tends to like really good and
and inside if you walk into their place
in Pomona feels like you're walking into
East LA it just brings back childhood
memories or nice to get mugged private
investigator bakery oh hell yeah so
Jimmy Jimmy okay so because of you
how do we meet well remember we met with
the good friend time on my al-mal
contact with his radio
in the high desert what's your bottle
girl and she bought some of them I
actually I don't know but i'm mocchi
listen read there's many years out in
the in the high desert okay and we
hooked that we have so much in conscious
being from east los you know chad enough
that way that's dad we're not in East LA
and just a lot of stuff you know and
then also my sister passed away about 21
years now yeah so we had a lot of we had
a lot in common
only his only sister was shot Paula
pushy yeah I never mentioned that before
but I guess she's right here with my
demonic my three demons I've got here
just through somehow of Indy townhomes
1942 after Judy J before in the past I
know I look like they say I look like a
famous Spanish to me no I'm not gonna
drop his name yeah you do it the Hat
take you down dude that'd be me
we're good you know that huge right
short guy right a short dude and yes big
mouth like Brock yes like piranha he
does weird G brothers that's right I
used to do it on our Spanish radio FM
radio I'm not gonna mention their names
but I used to do it on Spanish radio and
then yeah I got I talked with the how I
became famous that quick how did you
hear about poor odious play huh well I
know I know I I'm not I'm not coming up
I know Jerry I know Jerry Velasco
Kimball asked
so height Omani so we know we know Jerry
Velasco invited us down to the pitch and
I had done a few things acting you know
I did a couple things I came out with a
few people that were actually there that
Montezuma's far as a producer and they
walk out Zuma and and and I was part of
that and this is nice to be around the
rasa and the people with their father
he look like he was going to say he
lives in El Sereno or I should say no
it's like tut-tut eat or something like
that all right I was like dude you live
down the street from my house because I
grew up in now I say all right Parkside
Lincoln Heights and this guy goes oh
yeah Cheech Maureen's gonna take care of
that part because I represent Boyle
Heights fool Oh online knows the
funniest day on Instagram way back when
but anyway it's really nice to be here
is amazing so 2020 everyone laughs we're
here Larry winner for 2020 is trump
gonna win or what 2020 I've always said
you know the minority is a majority it's
not about the money you make it's what
you could bring to the table we brought
it tonight not because of 1942 but for
1969 hello chin hoping we're chill might
be nothing we're a fool you know and I
believe I gotta say it right here right
now I love you're embracing where we
come from you're doing I know it's
intimidating I don't know what the hell
I was doing on Sunday but I spoke
Spanish even though my parents are
wetbacks I'm a [ __ ] born here I
didn't know what I was doing but I was
you're powering here you're not a way
back and I take it I say
it's very it's sad because I know if
anybody feels the same way deep down
inside he will know we're not from there
we're not from here
we're from where no man I'll win them
it's kind of hard I'm sorry that Guinea
so yeah yeah no sorry back key nice way
there yeah yeah and like Selena herself
and Chris Perez I love you honey
call me later go [ __ ] girl right now I
know Philippe it's really hard for us to
be Mexican because we were born here but
I was you're amazing you're amazing but
we were raised here yes yes and the
thing is it's kind of hard for us I have
a hard time speaking Spanish because I
think English por que takes a lot of
balls Felipe and I thank I mean
personally thank you and I have it in my
in my heart in my soul when my dad did
that we get talent and we bring you to
the top so whatever I can do for you oh
yeah I'm there for you I love you I
don't even know you
I love her more
white girls all right we get it thank
you very much happy holidays everybody
yeah thank you for
[Applause]